mighty joe mansion that's the focus
of tonight's angle
democrats want americans to think that
they represent the vanguard against
all extremism and that they only go to
political war when they need to defeat
alleged radicals like donald trump
but the truth is the democrat party
itself has become a haven
for far-left fanatics and like all
fanatics
they demand complete and total
conformity of thought on all of their
pet issues
from the minimum wage to immigration
amnesty
to things like transgender rights get in
line
or risk getting smeared well such has
been the experience of west virginia
senator joe manchin now that he's
decided to make the obvious choice to
oppose
president biden's omb pick near a tandem
now manchin's decision wasn't arbitrary
it was sensible
tandon like so many other biden cabinet
and sub-cabinet picks like deb howland
for interior javier becerra and rachel
levine at hhs
it's an obscenely stupid and polarizing
choice
a venomous hack tandon has sprayed
conservatives
including sitting u.s senators with
gratuitous
and groundless attacks she's also a
conspiracy theorist in russia hoax super
spreader
and if that's not enough to can her
nomination she's also displayed
terrible judgment according to buzzfeed
as the president of the center for
american progress tandon
outed an anonymous staffer who had
accused her manager
of sexual assault and she did it during
a staff meeting no less
ten years earlier as a clinton campaign
aide tandon reportedly
punched a liberal reporter who asked
hillary about her support for the iraq
war
now when she was pressed about the
incident tandon told the new york times
i didn't slug him i pushed him
the question here shouldn't be why is
joe manchin
opposing tandon for a cabinet level post
the question should be why the hell did
joe biden
ever pick a left-wing hatchet woman in
that position in the first place
of course the ladies of cable can't
conceive of the fact
that tandon was a moronic choice so
instead
they just do what they always do they
play the gender card
her history of having said things like
oh calling mitch mcconnell
voldemort or calling ted cruz heartless
that is what violates this new line a
line that he did not apply or even
reference
when considering dudes nominated by
trump
all of this has led noted conservative
bill crystal to say of tandem quote
i feel like there's a little bit of
sexism going on here
so weak why go there why not just defend
the nomination
on substantive grounds i can tell you
why
because tanden's qualifications are
really flimsy that's why
raising money for left-wing causes and
attacking republicans on the internet
hardly qualifies you to run the office
of management and budget
but if the sexism line isn't selling
well you can count on the democrats to
revert to their old standby
racism as in anyone who criticizes
any of the president's nominations is a
racist
it's president biden's nominees of color
who have faced outsized opposition i
guess since his trolling was bipartisan
that was okay by old joe manchin
what's up with you mansion divo much
of course people like joy reid are some
of the most illiberal people on the
planet
and meanwhile over at cnn today a
daytime host was
bemoaning the simple math of the u.s
senate
it's unfortunate that he comes from a
state which is
not particularly representative of the
most of the country
it's a largely rural state and
a mineral producing state and
so much of the gdp of the country comes
elsewhere from elsewhere
but it is what it is
and you know what else is what it is
that you sir
are an odious snob who regards west
virginians and mansion
the same way you know they regard
president trump
as deplorable now what terrifies today's
democrats i think the most is the
prospect that come november 2022
they and their job-killing policies are
going to be exposed
that millions of voters will decide they
want their freedom back
and that all the radical nonsense bidens
team pushed
failed spectacularly which of course it
will
democrats have the slimmest of margins
in the senate and thus
they're moving radical executive orders
and destructive legislation through as
fast as they can
they're desperate to prevent anyone with
trump's views
from winning national office ever again
thus their introduction of the so-called
for the
people act which is anything but if that
becomes law it would mandate
nationwide automatic and same-day voter
registration
well the feds would also be in control
of early voting
and vote by mail no problem with fraud
there of course
and of course if you oppose this
takeover of senate and state
state voting prerogatives then you're
racist hank johnson a georgia democrat
co-sponsoring the bill
claims if left to their own devices
republicans will try to limit the
ability of minority voters to exercise
their fundamental right to vote
democrats know that trump made gains
with minority voters and
i'm telling you they plan to block this
going forward
by splunk it going forward by starting
commissions
to claim that republicans are white
supremacists hiding in sleeper cells all
across america
they're just waiting by the way to be
activated
it's also transparent it's predictable
and it's
totally dishonest and in so many other
areas
as as in so many other areas democrats
are making huge mistakes by vilifying
people like mansion while elevating
hardcore radicals like tandon
biden's going to find out the hard way
that voters they didn't give him a
mandate to remake america
his only mandate was maybe to deal with
covid and reopen
america and we know dr fauci
isn't about to let that happen anytime
soon
hispanic and african-american voters
like so many americans
are tiring of these nonsensical
lockdowns we've been warning you about
these since last april
and they're really worried especially
when it comes to the schools
and the kids and republicans will be
there
every step of the way to remind those
voters
the party that kept them locked down and
which party
wanted them to be free so i have to ask
why does joe manchin even want to put up
with this nonsense anymore
the party of radicals and reparations
that left him a long time ago
democrat leaders patronize and humor
mansion
when they need his vote but at this
point it's just obvious that they simply
hate him
and they hate his constituents as well
imagine continuing
for instance being a member in a club
that detests
you and the people closest to you
i can't either and that's the angle